the length of the fingers and
particularly the second and the fourth
digits are determined during development
by the load of testosterone from the
mother that the fetus is exposed to the
higher that is the shorter the index
finger is shorter index finger means
that you are on the whole more likely to
be promiscuous
do you ever find it annoying to be so
well known
for one landmark concept like dunbar's
number
um i have to say sometimes
but um you know
there are only about i'm told
uh
10 people who have a number named after
them and i'm the only one that's alive
no way
something like that wow
which is a bit worrying
oh you think that they're killing off
the people that numbers are named after
who knows yeah you never you never do
know so originally i wanted to talk
about friendships but we're going to do
that another time you have a book that
explains very interestingly from an
evolutionary psychology basis
what is happening when we fall in love
what happens when we fall out of love so
it's just an absolute primer
how do you define love what is it
i well i
i think
humans have spent the last
empty thousand years trying to figure
out how to define love and the answer is
it is very difficult um it's clear that
something weird goes on in the brain and
in fact the brain goes completely crazy
and
we kind of become fixated if you like is
what effectively happens on a particular
person
um
and uh
i mean it's
it's
kind of easy to describe
the appearance of somebody in love i
mean all the great poets and shakespeare
and et cetera et cetera kind of do it
extremely well essentially you know they
sort of dreamy
uh appearance and and they can't get the
person out of their mind and they want
to be near the person all these kind of
things but trying to understand what is
actually going on inside the mind
really has been a bit of a nightmare
but the reality is all cultures
have or experience
uh something very similar along these
lines that's not to say that every
person in the given culture experiences
some people are constantly falling in
love
and like
every time a new person comes in the
room they fall in love with them
and other people
don't fall in love particularly with
anybody yeah they get all fine with them
and they maybe have babies with them but
you know they're not
it's a bit give or take you know um
as you might say they they're not don't
have that sort of commitment so i
suppose there is a sense in which
there's a
feeling of commitment of
um
rosy sunglasses this person is the most
wonderful person i've ever met
all these kind of cliches you know
cliches are true based on observation of
fact
what makes us fall in love with somebody
then how can we reliably fall in love
with someone
oh i don't think you can i think it just
overwhelms you when you least expect it
and sometimes
it can happen
uh
if you like after the event so one of
the characteristic things that of people
who have
been in arranged marriages will tell you
is you know you get
ordered by your parents to bury this
person
and you think oh my god um and then you
know lo and behold a little way in you
kind of just fall in love with them and
it just seems to work like that i mean
you know
we
uh kind of prefer to fall in love first
before you marry people well you know
that doesn't always work out either
so you know there is no
no rule
uh that's universal to these things it
sometimes happens it sometimes doesn't
it's hard to say
i would figure anyway hard to say
why it happens in particular cases often
we don't really know it's it's it really
is
one of the great mysteries of the
universe and it's a great trauma
very often well that's the thing right
it's not just an enjoyable experience it
can often cause
the worst psychological pain that many
people will go through in their lives
oh yes i mean if you look at
you know all the great
love poetry from the
wonderful stuff the persians produced
and the arabs produced
um right the way through to to to the
modern day even in
poetry love poetry of other um you know
sort of
non-euro middle eastern cultures
elsewhere in the world it's it's all
very similar it's the it's the
trauma of unrequited love that
it really carries the weight as it were
you know sort of what do you think's
happening evolutionarily there is that
somebody lusting after someone and
fearing that they are being told their
genes are not good enough
that sounds very cruel
look i'm i'm trying to break it down
into your language here
robin unless you want to start
pontificating about some romance
language poetry stuff
well
the great mystery is why we have
this
kind of uh falling in love phenomenon
now we might think of it in terms of
pair bonding because what it does is
create this very intense
emotionally intense
pair bond between two people
and that
is kind of unusual it's certainly very
unusual in mammals to have those kind of
one-on-one monogamous relationships the
only
group of um mammals that is uh 100
percent monogamous in that sense
actually the dog families are the wolves
and the foxes and all that a lot
um
most mammals aren't they're promiscuous
or they you know have kind of
harem type
mating systems families male and several
females
and females sorry humans have this very
peculiar
halfway house which is
something that looks like monogamy
in the sense that it's you've got this
very strong pair bond that holds uh two
people together
but unlike all the
um
proper
properly monogamous
mammals like dogs and gibbons and
various other species of monkeys that
are going for this kind of thing
you know these relationships aren't
lifelong
humans have a form of serial monogamy in
which
people tend to move from one
relationship to another
on average as it was is not say that
some people don't have lifelong
relationships
any more than some people have no
relationships at all
um
on average you know most people probably
go through a number of these
relationships some of which are
uh just you know sort of teenage crushes
phase and then you know you end up
marrying somebody
um and maybe you know you park company
and go off and marry somebody else and
that may happen
two or three times and it can happen a
lot in in some
untogether societies where you know they
may have
eight or ten partners in a in a life
lifetime each partnership
each romantic partnership if you like to
think of it in those terms is quite
robust and they don't last for a number
of years and
they get fed up with each other i
suppose
is serial monogamy
what you would
guess
ancestrally is this sort of i guess
natural state of affairs on average
not really um
for humans it appears to be something
more chimpanzee-like which is
uh
polygamy in some form either
promiscuous polygamy as it it
just think in terms of the way
chimpanzees uh
society works the the males fight it out
amongst themselves
and the the top dog then gets to mate
with all the females and this doesn't
mean to say that the males further down
the hierarchy
don't uh occasionally mate with females
they often do they try and sneak them
off into the bushes where nobody's
watching
um but they don't have a sort of
permanent relationship
um
the females rear the their offspring are
aided by the males and males may be
contributing by defending a territory or
something like that or keeping other
males strange males away from the group
but the males aren't really particularly
involved in
in child care and child rearing
um
you might get some relationships that
last longer there's a tendency
for these kind of systems you see this
in the gorillas particularly where
several females are locked onto one male
so the males
in those sort of contexts are
as kind of
sumo wrestlers if you like they're the
big
thugs that keep everybody else off you
off your back
sperm donor and bodyguard
absolutely and this is sometimes known
as the bodyguard hypothesis
um
and we kind of see that in humans too
a little bit
um but by and large most human societies
are actually polygamous let's say you
have a male with several wives have you
got an idea of the upper bound of that
um
i i well if you look at some of the
famous
uh um emirs of
morocco places or
um you know the the um
uh emperors of uh uh the the mughal
state in in in north india can run into
king solomon i suppose is the other
famous example run into many hundreds if
not thousands of
wives and concubines between them um
but on the whole the problem is that you
know if you have a few few males doing
that that means there's an awful lot of
males at the bottom of the hierarchy who
don't get a wife period um unless they
go around stealing them from
uh you know other cultures
and either of the other tribes either of
those make for a pretty unstable society
it it makes for a very unstable society
and one of the consequences of this
in almost all these societies
historically is
when the grand old man dies he's got
like a hundred sons
all of whom are gunning for each other
um to
be take his place as the next emperor so
there's an absolute bloodbath usually of
of rivals because to the victor the
spoils to the victor all the spoils and
the spoils are very very rich indeed in
these cases
it's not unusual i mean that's basically
what happened under
the saxon kings in england and it
happened in scotland with the scottish
kings really quite late running through
into the 12
uh or even 1300s um you know they
they were just you would just end up
with
an almighty um
mess basically as different families
fought over
who who was going to be the next the
next king sometimes while the king
previously was still alive
and uh he didn't survive much longer
once they'd sorted out who is you've got
to prepare you know it's like getting
ready for a night out the event is
coming we might as well make sure that
we're all set so
given the fact that
you were of the opinion that uh polygamy
is typical ancestrally or at least on
average would have been not uncommon
how on earth is it that we have managed
to wrangle anything close to a
monogamous society even if it's serial
monogamy okay
um i mean i think it's important to see
this in the context that what evidence
there is
which is mostly
to do with the length of the finger
bones
which is quite a good measure of how
promiscuous society is
all our ancestral species going back to
the australopithecines seem to have been
polygamous
they they show a strong anatomical
signature of polygamy it's only modern
humans that's this what's known as the
2d 4d ratio the ratio of the
index finger to the ring finger
talk to me about how you can tell
the
dating preferences of a society based on
the
ratio of their fingers
um it it
sounds bizarre doesn't it but it seems
to work quite well and and this was
established
both in in animals and in humans it
works quite well in primates
but it seems that the genes that control
the length of the fingers and
particularly the second and the fourth
digit so your
index finger and your
ring finger are determined
uh by
uh or or are influenced during
development by testosterone load
uh in in the womb so the fetal uh the
load that the fetus is of testosterone
from the mother that the fetus is
exposed to
um the higher that is
um
the
uh shorter
the the index finger is
so more testosterone is shorter index
finger yes shorter index finger means
that um
you
are on the whole more
likely to be promiscuous and they and
it's kind of indicative of high
testosterone levels then both internally
to you so some
male babies because they're obviously
switching over
uh from being a kind of generic
um
non-sex so so female body form is the
default
yeah
i remember i don't i got to interject
there there is a um i think it's called
gone girl which was a movie kind of a
thriller movie a few years ago i'm
pretty sure that the line was in that
and the the female protagonist in it is
very manipulative and
she
uses this line that would have slipped
under the radar for a lot of people but
she points at the guy and she says the
male form is an aberration
and that's so cool right because it's
the reason that men have got nipples
right you need to be born with all of
the
elements all of the individual bits that
could make a woman and then
you you turn from a kind of nothingness
that could be a woman into a man and
then that was why she said she pointed
at him and she says the male form is an
aberration
yeah well this is also what's known
um as the race to be male because it
depends on how fast
the fetus grows so it's a combination
of having a y chromosome
and
how how how much fat the baby lays lays
down and that switches the brain over
from this kind of generic female brain
into a male brain which is clearly
missing lots of bits that should be
there as a result okay so what you were
saying before the finger length
that isn't the determinant of the dating
preference that is simply a
manifestation of testosterone levels
testosterone is
so you're saying shorter index finger
more testosterone it would appear more
testosterone also correlated with
shorter monogamous partnerships
normally it would be
either totally promiscuous mating
systems or mating systems in which males
compete with each other
for to monopolize groups of females so
what sometimes there's a harm-based um
social system where you have one male 1
and a number of females in their
offspring
so species like gibbons which are
obligately monogamous very occasionally
they might have two maybe even three
females
exceptionally in their little group uh
but you know 98 of gibbon groups in the
wild
are strictly monogamous and the pair
stays together for effectively for life
very long index fingers
no no they're very equal right
uh and and if you look at monogamous
species sorry polygamous species of
primates they then tend to have both
both sexes will have
index fingers which are
shorter than
the ring finger but
the more promiscuous sex
will have
relatively shorter
index finger
compared to the female so the males who
tend to be the more promiscuous sex
even in
um
promiscuous species will have uh
uh
a more deviant
um uh
finger ratio than the female as well and
you see that in humans as well
women's tens of thousands of people
right now looking at their hands yes i
know and working out
whether or not they're whether or not
their digits justify their desire to
cheat or to go out and have sex with
somebody tonight
yes well
well
you have to be a little bit careful
because the padding of the flesh and the
muscles around the finger bases
disguises the point where you should be
measuring from right so you you need to
find the joint between the
um
finger
the bottom finger bone and the
top end of the first
hand bone if you like
um
and and and the differences are very
very small they would be hard to tell by
eye although i have seen some
males with spectacularly short
index fingers
which is just blindingly obvious and you
take one look at them in their behavior
and you go yes
you're an absolute bastard basically
not just
not just in the world of of romance but
in the world of work you know just yeah
testosterone coursing through them yes
yes i mean just fizzing okay so let's
get back to love itself i i i i'm still
not sure about how love is adaptive like
is it just
ratcheted up attachment it seems odd
that we've evolved to feel something
that's so weird and has so many
downsides
well
this is where it all gets a bit murky
because it's not
really obvious why humans should have
these kind of pair bonded
if you like to think of them as
semi-monogamous i think the fact that we
have this capacity
just going back to your earlier question
is what makes it possible
then to have monogamous
arrangements
imposed on us because
if you look at the 8 000 or so societies
around the world that's about 8 000
languages in each language different
society
um
the vast majority are
polygamous and um you know sort of a few
men at the top right now
yes well even now yes unless they've
been christianized the point is
the societies that um aren't polygamists
that
pursue a monogamous
family structure are either
hunter-gatherers
and so the differences between males
aren't very great
for the females to choose between
doesn't you know this one can maybe hunt
a bit better than another but you know
by and large the differences are quite
minimal or
they're primarily
being subjected to christianization
which has imposed
strict monogamy or attempted to impose
strict monogamy
um
if you look at
well and i guess the answer is it
doesn't work very well because we just
have serial monogamy instead which is
effectively the same thing and of course
there are some christian cults think of
some of the mormon
breakaway cults and the original mormons
who first started it um are still
polygamous and operational
well yes
the issue though
is
what seems to
drive polygamy
in um uh human societies
is when you got massive wealth
differentials this is why you get the
king solomon's type of uh
um you know or the great khans or you
know i mean there's this extraordinary
uh statistic from the genetics which
tells us that one percent of all the
males alive today
are the descendants of genghis khan or
his brothers
and within the area of the mongol empire
that he and his brothers as his generals
conquer at seven percent of all living
males are their descendants you know
well you know it's easy to see why it's
because every time a city refused to
capitulate to them
they overran them very quickly they
killed all the men and they took the
women into their
harems and that was the end of that
um you know so they inevitably produced
huge numbers of descendants
but it's remarkable that we can still
pick that signature up now you know sort
of
uh what is it
six seven hundred years later it does
seem strange that we've got the
if we're
leaning towards uh polygamy as soon as
we have these surplus resources to be
able to afford a stratified hierarchy of
men and men to be able to support many
women and stuff
it kind of is strange that we've got the
mental faculties for love to be such a
compelling overbearing
emotion for men as well right
yes um that's true but i mean it's just
kind of um worth pointing out uh first
though
that um
these polygamous societies
uh are all
ones with very very
um wide spread of wealth so you've got
very very rich people very very poor
people which and the rich people the
rich males
become attractive to the women
because of what they have on to offer
not for themselves but in terms of
wealth because the big problem all
human societies face but particularly so
once they're kind of into the
agricultural game
as it were no longer hunting hunters and
gatherers
is that
the better off you are the more likely
your children will survive
you know we know that from our societies
here in a
modern britain it's
in
absurdly
still still still the same if you come
from the you know the poor end of
society your children are much more
likely to get ill and much more likely
to die
um so the issue the issue the trade-offs
kind of women all around the world are
operating with
is is it better to be the second wife of
a very very rich man and therefore have
a big cut
of of let's say the land for you to grow
crops on
than be you know the first wife of a
very poor man
and the interesting thing about
um
falling in love and romantic
relationships generally
is the extent to which people are
willing to compromise on their ideals
in order to just get the best job they
can get
under the circumstances they face
in other words you know
everybody wants to
uh marry mr darcy
but unfortunately there's only one of
him and
500 of you
so as uh you know what do the rest of
you do
as uh jane austen
with her acute observation of the
foibles of humans
uh
observes is you hang on and you hang on
you hang on hoping to catch mr darcy or
one of the other rich landowners until
you the point you get to is the point of
no return where you go if i don't marry
soon i'm going to be too old to have
children it's basically what it is so
you marry the curing
right
you wouldn't have looked at him twice
but it's the best you can do
and at that point
the whole system will flip in and you
fall in love with him
yeah so completely mad this is what you
were talking about kind of earlier on to
do with the
arranged marriages i guess that
well two things maybe are happening here
first is that subconsciously uh woman's
programming is um reacting to her
ecology and her biological age and kind
of this ticking time clock to adjust her
attraction levels based on um basically
scarcity
and another element is
it would seem like closeness
physical closeness and familiarity can
breed love yes that's what it seems
comes from the indian arranged marriage
like you literally do not know this
person and the very well the matchmaking
job may have been done perfectly and you
may have fallen in love with this person
but i would guess that tons and tons and
tons of people in arranged marriages
fall in love more out of familiarity and
closeness than
some
predestined sense of compatibility yes
yeah i'm i'm absolutely sure that's the
case um but the
the issue then is
why
uh you have you know you what you have
if you like is the generic system for
human seems to be a form of polygamy
that's the almost the default
um
uh why would you have
a kind of this kind of romantic
component to it this this very strong
pair bond because you get that
in polygamous marriages you know that's
what happens
um
when when a new wife is taken on you
know um it's not because
well sometimes it's because the the the
first wife who is always becomes the
chief wife says
you're boring go and find another little
one
to play with
um i mean literally that that you know
is the kind of thing that happens or
um the the husband actually falls in
love with somebody else and wants to
bring bring this new wife younger always
always younger into
um the household
and then it's a trade-off for the
first wife or this this is the third
wife of the first two wives as to
whether they're happy with that
arrangement or whether they just shrug
their shoulders and go
we can live our lives quite happily
without uh
having to be
bothered by
the the husband as they were
um so
it's still a mystery in that sense so
the question then is you know what's
underpinned the evolution of this kind
of
romantic falling in love component
so the classic answer has always been
well it must be
the need for bi parental care human
babies are
born absolutely premature by a whole
year
um that's why they're all kind of floppy
and useless and you know
don't even smile at you never mind
be you know behave in a an engagingly
human way you need something
uh
to to to
sort of persuade you to keep investing
in it until it's
have completed its growth that all other
monk monkey snapes do before birth
um and starts to if you like become more
seriously human
and it that is so taxing
for the mother that having
somebody else around why not the male
uh to help out is um absolutely
necessary
and you kind of go well that sounds
awfully like american culture to me
um you know where in the world does that
actually happen and the answer is well
you know sometimes the not together
societies you know the men daniel babies
on their knees and do things like that
just as all men everywhere do
um
change your nappy here and there but
they're not really that good at um
helping out you know they're much better
when when when the kids are
old enough to you know fire a bow and
arrow and learn how to do these kind of
uh useful tasks
so i deeply suspect the amount of
paternal care that humans give despite
desperate efforts to uh claim that it's
part of our
nature uh simply isn't the reason at all
um
uh and and that's because in the end the
people who are most valuable to the
mother
in almost all societies and just as much
in ours as anybody else is
is
the grandmother
and the sisters
and maybe your female best friend
that these are the ones that really make
the the business of particularly those
early years
um uh
possible if you're like less
trouble-free than they might be do on
your own
and and you know sort of yes males are
useful um
uh if their
own land that you can you can farm and
produce you know lots of crops to feed
your
children on and all those kind of things
and we know that's important we know
from
um historical demography data for
example um from europe that in in the
18th and 19th centuries that
women whose husbands were
landed peasantries so they only had a
few acres
you know they weren't the nobility they
weren't even middle class they were
peasants
you know a bit like cros crofters you
might say in in scotland you know
they've got
five
acres of land or something like that and
they can grow a few the more land
uh the husband had
the better the survival chances of of
the wife's children
were and of course you know for landless
peasants who day laborers that they are
the only
way they could earn a living was to hire
themselves out by the day to help with
other people's farms you know their
wives you know had high mortality rates
because
when they needed to go to the doctor
they didn't have the odd fiver
to spare for the doctor's fee they you
know if
they couldn't didn't have any money they
couldn't buy any food all these kind of
things piling in on them the same old
story
that we even now you know still have to
cope with
um so
you know yes once you have agriculture
uh once you have wealth uh accumulating
then then the males can contribute
indirectly
but that's comes late you know that
doesn't happen until
8 000 years ago with a neolithic
agricultural revolution prior to that
for
several million years
or lineage um you know just hunter
gatherers so
those kind of issues
don't necessarily um come work out and
you know in typically anyway you might
say well maybe
a husband who's a particularly good
hunter is the equivalent thing and the
answer is
not really
in hunter-gatherer societies because if
he's a good hunter and he can bring down
mammoths
instead of you know a chicken
always in those societies those big um
prey
uh that are hunted are shared
with the whole
camp it's only small things
um that you eat within the family of the
hunter on their own so you know
it seems to me there really isn't all
that much evidence to support the claim
that
this romantic relationship is there for
um
by parental care as such as as the
technical term is
and the the only obvious answer
seems to be
this is a hard gun problem
right so what it ineffected is happening
is that the females wanting to attach
themselves to a particular male
essentially for protection
and
in the kind of size of societies we
lived in
this is only going to work terribly well
if if if you've got both sexes locked
onto each other so the male has to be
prepared to it has to in effect fall in
love as well at the same time
um and the reason for saying that um
goes to
um
the fact
recent evidence um there's only just
been published
that for mammals in general i say all
mammals from you know your humble
local mouse and vole
right the way through to humans
uh the bigger the group
uh you live in the
lower the fertility of the females
now mammals in general
it's a very linear decline so if you
look at things like voles and
rodents of various kinds then the bigger
the social group the more females in the
social group
the lower the fertility but what smart
species as you might call them like
lions
primates uh
monkeys that live in
intensely bonded social stable social
groups
and have formed coalitions are able to
do is shift that decline in fertility
towards a bigger group size that they
can live in bigger groups for protection
mostly against predators the offset of
the bigger group with extra protection
yeah is better than it would be if you
were able to have tons of kids but what
happens is you you know
there's only so far you can push
that that effect uh over to allow you to
live in bigger groups because in the end
that that that
decline in fertility catches up what you
see in those
species is a is an inverted u-shaped
relationship between
uh female fertility average female
fertility and
the size of the group right so if it's
the group's too small
females do rather badly
these species indicating these species
it pays to be in groups because that
solves an ecological problem for you but
there just comes a point where
these
negative effects on facilities start to
overwhelm the positive effects now the
question is what's or who is causing
those effects well
for 40 years
i confess
i've been studying various
mammals
feral goats in particular because they
go crazy
in the mating season
on in the belief that and therefore
looking for evidence and explanations
for the fact that
males going crazy during the rut
as red deer do and feral goats do and so
on many other antelope do
um
is so stressful for the females that it
causes infertility
right so you know the assumption is here
it's it's it's it's the motorbike gangs
roaring around the village at midnight
that's kind of making everybody jumpy
and stressed and that's what and we know
that psychological stress uh suppresses
fertility the menstrual uh endocrinology
in mammals and
women are no different is incredibly
sensitive
and you have high levels of stress and
this is partly
in order to ensure that you don't
uh have a
a menstrual cycle while you're lactating
right
so this
because that would mean you're having to
to gestate and lactate for
uh babies at the same time oh so there's
an adaptive reason for why babies make
you stressed yes well not make you
stressed the system is just designed so
that baby suckling shuts down the
menstrual cycle right i learned from i
think it's christian jarrett personality
psychologist not long ago that women who
are toward the bottom of their
social hierarchy can be so downtrodden
uh in terms of status that they can shut
off their reproductive cycle as well
yes well this is this is exactly what's
driving the thing because when we looked
at the data from primates it turns out
it's nothing to do with males at all
sometimes males can be quite useful
but
what's driving is is
something going on between the females
they're squabbling
amongst themselves and it's that stress
so this is not fighting
this is just what i sometimes describe
as
the london commuter experience you know
you're just being jostled and hassled
right on the underground you're very
sensitive of status but the issue being
that because it still takes nine months
to birth a child a woman who is
maximally fertile still has a relatively
limited number of children so it's not
like the woman that is at the top could
give birth to so many that the group
size could basically be be unlimited you
still have a limit on the top
and then the women that are toward the
bottom if the group size gets too big
there's too much hierarchy there's too
much infighting too much squabbling too
much social pressure yeah that's causing
a
drop in the that's right
and the prob the problem is that once
you push group size limits they can see
this in species after species after
species of primates and you see it in
lions you see it in as i said in in some
of the social monkeys for example
if if the
further you push group size or the
number of females in the group
corr the correct thing
um
the bigger the effect on everybody so
even though the top-ranking female is
still pumping babies out
the other nine or ten are being pushed
so low
that the group actually can't replace
itself
okay
um and this is what seems to
uh cause or perhaps causes groups to
split because it's the females kind of
uh wanting out from a context where
they're just being pressured i mean you
know
we've known about these effects for a
very long time it's been known in
generally that stress um affects
fertility in women in humans there's the
classic work that was done on the uh
marmoset monkeys the caltrichevs uh from
south america
which shows that
um if if a a daughter stays in the group
she doesn't even go through puberty
because she's being harassed so much by
her mother
right uh take the mother out or put the
female with the subado female with
another male
and within a month she's gone through
puberty and she's cycling and she'll
conceive
it's absolutely extraordinary how how
fine-tuned this mechanism is it's like
plants
it's the way that plants respond to
their local ecology
this is true yes yeah crazy well you
know
you know species species that have to be
able to
combat varying circumstances whether
it's you know your local ecology as a
environment as a plant or the vagaries
of
the world in
general if you're in a complicated
mammal like a primate
you know flexibility of that kind is the
key to its success so and primates are
particularly safe now the issue here is
if you're having these stresses
the problem for humans
evolving away from our
common ancestor the common access of the
chimpanzees and the great um gorillas
the great apes of africa
so sometime around about
seven million years ago give or take a
bit
um they're pushing out eventually
actually during the astrology phase they
were kind of okay they were really
operating in a kind of
cheap chimpanzee type of environment a
rather impoverished chimpanzee
environment but you know they they don't
so any signs of uh
increasing group size but once you get
the genus homo
appearing
sort of humans if you like proper
two million years ago so our lineage
really taking off
what's what's that's what driven what's
driving that is a move or what that's
associated with it's a move out into
a much more nomadic lifestyle outside
the forests uh in less protected
environments and at that point you see
evidence in terms of brain size for
dramatically increasing group sizes now
what these species are all facing right
the way through to modern humans
is a need to live in very large groups
with lots of females
in the face of this pressure suppressing
you so if you're going to be able to
live in
these big groups somehow you have to
solve
the
fertility problem pressure now primates
have been doing that for 60 million
years
it's every time they you know you get a
new lineage inc that's sort of
increasing group size because occupying
more predator risky habitats
macaques
baboons ground dwelling species like
that
they're having to solve this fertility
problem the way they're doing it
predominantly is
uh through female female coalitions so
you form a
within the group close bond with
a um
uh a best grooming partner and the two
of you act as a buffer so you end up you
end up with the benefits of a large
overall tribe
and you ameliorate the effect of the
infertility by having a small flat
hierarchy little
microcosm within it
so we are you saying that
women females ancestrally and maybe even
today
need to
take care
of their status
of how statusful they are and how
they're feeling in terms of respect and
uh pressure yeah actually no they
they're much less worried about status
and risk i was using status i was using
status as a proxy i suppose for like um
psychological
oh turbulence or whatever it was that
presumably the women that would have the
most psychological turbulence would be
the ones that were the most downtrodden
yes i guess so that that that's uh about
how it is but the issue at this point is
you seem to have two choices
is you either form coalitions with other
females who
if you look at baboons and macaques and
like almost always close female
relatives
their little matrix matrilineal
groupings mum and two daughters or three
daughters maybe a kind of arrangement
or
uh you might choose to lock onto a male
so in gorillas you have all the females
locked onto a male they don't really
relate to each other at all
but most of the time it it's it's female
female bonds now in some species you get
a bit of both now the gelada baboon
seems to be one of the few which
operates both systems simultaneously and
that's because they live in such big
groups
right so what they have is little
harm-based groups where the females are
locked onto the male
which buffers them against living in
these very large grazing herds of
sometimes several hundred
uh monkeys milling around and treading
on each other's toes
and then of course that's exacerbating
the stresses within the little subgroup
harm subgroup so what they do there is
they buffer themselves by
against those by
um
uh forming these little female female
coalitions except for the female that's
got left out because she has no sisters
or mom or daughter to do it with and she
locks onto the mail uh yeah so you've
got two two potential solutions here
that's right and and they treat the male
exactly like he was a female in this
social sense right and he treats her
now i think what's happened with humans
this is kind of still a guess as it were
we're still trying to figure out how you
can improve it is what's happened is as
the group sizes have increased
it's become increasingly necessary for
females to lock on to males
as hired guns because females are no
good as hired guns then it's not what do
you mean when you say good guns
protectors cool bodyguard right
bodyguard yeah
is it not
okay so if it wasn't for the fact that
you need the physical protection of a
male because males are typically bigger
more aggressive more capable of doing
stuff
yeah
but there is one caveat to this is is
not necessary
that uh the the bodyguard as indeed is
the case when females are forming these
coalitions and uh in these other species
with other females female relatives
that this is a kind of
defensive pact uh by the military
full of
ak-47s pointing outwards
it's passive protection right it's just
that
i know
that when i am about to tread on your
toes that your best friend
is
five yards away and if you go ouch
i'm in trouble because i don't have to
contend just with you i'm gonna have to
contend with your best friend as well
and at that point primates are
smart
they know the odds are just not worth
fighting so they'll just detour slightly
round right so it most of it is passive
event now and again all passive defense
has to be proven at
some point
by
by genuine fisty cuffs if you like
otherwise it you know it
it doesn't really work but most of the
time it's just passive protection it's
having another partner that everybody
else knows
that's your buddy
so just don't mess unless you really
know you're going to win
is there a potential argument that this
reliance on is it aloe parenting i think
where you have it's sort of distributed
between women
women looking after multiple children
that not necessarily that
if it wasn't for the bodyguards issue or
the hide gun
element of having a male partner
could females not just have been
vegetarians not decided to go chase
something down it seems like you know
with uh menopause you do end up having a
surplus of women to be able to look
after children it's difficult to do that
like
i i can't remember it was in your book
or somewhere else that i read that
potentially the hunting part of hunter
gatherers for men
was more about judging male reproductive
fitness of whether he's a good hunter
more so than the nutrition that he
derived if that's true
that is one of the wildest things that
i've ever heard
now this is
this appears to be absolutely so that if
you look at the economic returns
of hunting
hunting
males like to go hunting big dangerous
animals in all these cultures right
um
the
energetic
returns on hunting big
um dangerous animals
and not that good not least because
they're just dangerous don't and you
have every chance of not coming home
yourself
right you actually do better
energetically
to just shoot rabbits
um but there's no
demonstration of skill so if you look at
male
um
courtship strategies if you like
it's all about demonstrating how good i
am
and
by good i mean how good my genes are
so if if all the kinds of things that
young males do
racing each other climbing stupidly high
cliffs
for no other purpose than to say i've
done it
playing
vigorously brutal games
where basically you're just bashing
heads together all these kinds of things
it's argued are
essentially displays of
just watch me i can afford to take these
risks because my genes are so good
they're the ones you want
and of course
there's no point in kind of making
vague claims these things have to be
proven right and the result is
teenage males have very high mortality
rates
by comparison with teenage girls because
they
take
so many more risks
i mean we've actually done done a study
on this
at a crossing in the middle of liverpool
watching uh
when people cross against the lights
and and what seems to happen is so we've
got a very nice measure of how risky it
is because we can measure how far away
the oncoming car is
if there are women present
in the crowd of people waiting to cross
males are much more likely to cross on
their own especially if the car is close
right
this is just advertising
um and you know it really is a case of
chicken because
you
you know it doesn't work if some people
don't pay the price because they get it
wrong
so
these pressures then seem to be spill
over in into honey there's the show off
uh explanation hypothesis for
for hunting
that's what it's called the show off
show off hypothesis wow i mean that that
is
absolutely spectacular to think
that it it might not be a utilitarian
i go out like
robin go robin stab robin bring back
it's not it's not about that it's about
look robin competent
with robin yes robin got very good genes
yeah yeah gene's build very good body
yes yes robin strong robin's son must be
attractive as well fast brain
yeah fast muscles okay
going back going back to the pair bond
stuff what what is commitment in your uh
mind then is it a hard to fake signal of
authenticity that sort of encourages
trust
basically yes i i think that's a lot of
i mean the problem this is a two-way
game this is not a game played by one
sex and the other sex just sort of sits
there and does nothing
um
uh
there is a caveat to that and and and
i'll just detour for a moment
because it does kind of sum up the
asymmetry of this so we we were looking
at
um a huge national telephone database so
this is
all the phone calls made on one provider
in a very large european country it's 20
of the entire country so we're talking
about
um
tens of millions of subscribers
and
something like six billion phone calls
over the course of a year
right now we were looking at the
uh
person they called most each person
called most
and what you see is um looking across
the age span so
as as is always the case we don't know
what happened below 18 because that that
becomes minor minors
and there's a whole nother ethics issue
so nobody ever bothers about them but
from 18 onwards what you find is
that the girls start very quickly
calling a particular number who is when
you check who that is
it's a male of similar age
it takes about three years before the
male starts to reciprocate and put a
female his age in that pole position
so in other words the girls have made up
their mind a long way beforehand
as to who they want and they call and
they call and they call and they make
sure they're there
when the guy comes around the corner all
these things until eventually even the
most stupid male goes oh goodness me
interesting interesting
doesn't this run against the
the over perception and under perception
bias
in this context meaning
just their phone calls i suppose so but
men men or at least david busts in his
new book he was talking about the fact
that men tend to over perceive
attraction from women and women tend to
understand attraction from men yes you
would have thought that like how how
high do you need to wave the flag men
should have already been
yes but but
you know
that
appears to be absolutely true but
men don't pursue that for very long i
think is the answer they think oh you
know she's showing an interest in me and
then they go oh no she's not actually
because the women are being very choosy
about
their responses to the males they make
it very clear sorry go away don't ring
me don't worry but the one they want
they will keep phoning
but what's interesting is and this bears
back on some of the other stuff we've
been talking about
is if you look at what happens after
that
um so this is a late marrying population
um
they
average age of marriage is about 29 in
that particular population at that
particular time
um
so they're they're really they're
they're um got this lead-in
as it were
in which the girls start very very very
early focusing on this one male the boys
eventually halfway through go all right
and then they get married and then about
20 years later almost exactly
suddenly
the wife
switches the girl switches
to a
female one generation younger
grandchild's just been born
but the male has long since already
switched out he's no longer phoning his
wife with the same frequency as he said
the females carries on phoning and
phoning phony the same person
but the male only lasts about seven
years you know
with her in poor position he then gets
if you like it gets bored and he starts
phoning other people
um
and and what this looks like is very
intense female choice going on
they're the ones that really decide
um it you know okay you can kind of
force them to marry you
in some way or another socially or
otherwise
um but you
it's it's a bad deal if you do that
because you're gonna have a very
uh grumpy wife
who didn't want to be there and probably
isn't gonna stay very long uh if you if
you respond to
the natural rhythm of the thing
then and let them choose then you're
into a good deal because you've got you
know
real focus and lock on
but it seems the guys just drift away
in their little social world as it were
much much earlier than the women do um
it's just so conspicuous when you see it
in the phone calling data what's the
lesson that you take away from that
oh well
one level is the choice is being made by
the women and it will work better if you
just leave them to it
the difficulty of course is is back to
jane austen she was such a good observer
of human human behavior
you know
people are being left out you know mr
darcy's getting all the girls
and you know the cure is getting none
except the desperate
um and you know because mr darcy's
getting such a lot of attention there
are a whole bunch of guys who aren't
getting any any
uh um wives at all and which is
effectively what happens in in polygamy
society so you have to have a way of
managing them
and you can see all sorts of interesting
strategies
um through history and across cultures
and how that problem is managed the
one suggestion has been this explains
why the portuguese started
their explorations in in the 15th
century because they had
re-conquered portugal from the moors
they'd taken over all the moorish
estates
the nobility that were created in the
aftermath of that
had enormous estates they were able to
uh
divide their estates equally between at
least their sons their daughters
probably got a bit of a share too
um
and you know everybody was
happy because they got a decent amount
of land but there came a point all over
europe this happened in fact
um
whereas states started to get carved up
into ever smaller pieces to the point
where they were no longer economic
so when this happened in portugal who
were the first people to really show
this um
they switched to primogeniture
oldest sun inherits everything so before
that all sons had inherited equally
they switched to primogeniture
that meant
the oldest son got the lot
the youngest sons kind of looked very
grumpy started to be a nuisance and
basically they were riding around them
in motorcycle gangs through the villages
playing mayhem
and beating the peasantry up and all
these kinds of things
that people will insist on doing um so
some some bright sparks said listen boys
you know why did you here's a boat when
you go exploring
and what you find is that a it led to
this huge uh
exploration and conquest of of
you know the new world and and uh the
east
um and you what you find is the old
oldest born son dies in portugal the
second and the third born son die in the
empire morocco or somewhere else they
just get them out of the system go and
make your own way so you're saying that
when the demand for potential mates
outstrips the available supply but you
have a surplus of resources
you can basically pay
men
to go off and have an adventure find
some more women find their own little
kingdom that they can go make somewhere
so you can control
single
disgruntled nuisance-causing men
by using the thing that you do have a
surplus of which is resources and money
you'll be you don't necessarily need
money i mean you just say go you know
because this is how the venetians solved
the problem they they never had this
problem right they they maintained
uh equal division of the family wealth
between all the sons you know for
centuries
because they were traders
right
the more suns you have the more trading
you can do
the problem with land is it's a fixed
commodity and you see this very nicely
illustrated
in the tibetans
so that
traditionally the tibetans
one of the few societies that practice
polyandry they have eat
one wife and many husbands the husbands
are all brothers
and this is a strategy to prevent so
what you're dealing with here is very
high altitude very poor quality land uh
and not much of it at that
um and every time you divide the family
estate up
uh between all the sons you know it very
quickly gets down to one field of peace
and that's not enough to keep anybody
going so their solution is to marry all
the brothers
to one girl from another family
because and the strategy works because
the brothers of different ages says you
know
when four or five brothers marry a girl
the oldest will be 21 22 something like
that the youngest will be five
they all go in as and they're all
treated as husband by the way but
because of the age differentials
uh they kind of operate
what's effectively a form of serial
monogamy because by the time the next
brother gets old enough to go oh the
first one's bored
oh my god except for
except for number two
right because number two is 18 when they
get married it's older brothers let's
say 22.
the next one is 17 or 18. now these he's
on the right on the the hinge as it were
of getting interested in girls
so what do they do they stick him in a
monastery so all these this is why the
tibetans have this huge
monastic culture
it part of it is to absorb
um the the excess suns who are always
the second born son wow you really
didn't want to be the second born then
that was a bad it depends on how much
you like the monastery i suppose and
whether you want your older brother's
ex-wife as your future partner
the interesting thing is you see exactly
the same thing happening in ireland so
we showed looking at
the seminary records for one major
seminary in ireland through the 19th
century
that the seminaries were filled with the
younger sons of big families
right they're all farmers they're all
you know petty farmers of one size or
when the family got too many boys in
them girls you can always marry off
right it's no problem when you've got
too many sons uh
you've got competition for the land so
uh you know if if they were a family
with a lot of sons then you know the
excess suns were persuaded that uh
a career in the church you're not gonna
get attracted you're not gonna get as
disgruntled in the parish perhaps if
you've decided to commit yourself to god
okay so you you looked at you know they
live very well you know the church looks
after them they get to travel you know
they might go to rome and become
incredibly rich as a cardinal all these
kind of things all these attractions to
make it but the the losers here in these
kind of systems sticking in the demand
system is
the other daughters because
uh you can you're only marrying one
daughter out of each family into another
family so you end up with surplus of
daughters and and for better or for
worse they end up as drudges in you know
their sisters or their brothers
households literally as servants
in leading a very miserable life
but the portuguese had that problem too
you know they ended up because they
wouldn't
allow their daughters to marry out of
the duke or
uh
uh class
right the the class of the top noble
class of dukes got a big constraint on
the supply yeah that's right now so what
do you do with all these surplus girls
you put them in a nunnery
and these girls went in
with the title of brides of christ
that's what they were called they went
in with a dowry
and if their older sister died
before
marriage or
soon after marriage before she'd
produced an heir
the next girl could relinquish her
nunnery vows
um
and go back uh and uh replace her
i can't imagine i can imagine that if
your parents you know they're awful
they're so manipulative they are i can
imagine that if you were a
disgruntled
unwilling nun
that knowing that if your sister died at
some point soon your older sister died i
imagine that that could create some
perverse incentives down the road if you
were a a particularly uh
wiry wiry little nun okay so one of the
things that i thought was fascinating
that you looked at was uh kissing the
use of human kissing what's what's the
explanation for that
uh
it it's one of those things again for
which there is never been really a
satisfactory explanation
um
one of the interesting things about
kissing though is in mouth-to-mouth
kissing i mean not all cultures do it so
it doesn't necessarily work
everywhere but it it seems that pretty
much it's as close to universal as
anything uh might be in that you know
large numbers of cultures actually do it
the key to it
is you're exchanging information
on your essentially your immune system
so it's reckoned a five-minute kiss
results in the transmission from one
person to the other
of tens of billions of
um uh
chemicals and uh
you know sort of bacteria and all sorts
of other things that that belong to your
insides
um to the other person and it's giving
them a very direct measure
of the quality of your immune system so
if you think about
falling in love
courtship in other words as a process of
assessment
so it starts since you enter the room
and your eyes lock across the room and
you go oh that's a very attractive one
that
uh phil's ticks all those kind of
physical attraction boxes i i shall go
and explore further and you
go closer and
engage in conversation
and so then you're picking up all sorts
of cues about their
their back cultural background if you
like them how they think and
psychological background and in the
conversation and then if you're still if
you're still happy
at that point you kind of go through a
point of reappraisal do i like what i
see or do i pull out now
when i i still can or do i go to the
next level he goes to the next level
it's a bit more sort of physical so you
you you have a grapple and a dance
um and at this point you can you can get
a good sniff of the other person uh
smell uh what they're saying important
in human very important very important
because again the same genes that
determine your smell
are the ones that determine your
immune system
right and what you're looking for
is somebody who has a different immune
system
it seems that what what you're looking
for is somebody who
kind of looks like you in all sorts of
ways so it's keeping a good bunch of
genes together from your
extended family if you like
this is what's known as optimal
inbreeding or optimal out breeding you
know
you know why would you waste the fact
that
history of
mating in your ancestors produce this
perfect
person that is you
why would you waste all that
by dispersing it by marrying
or mating with people who
are
not so perfect as you right so the
answer is
you look for people who are
similar to you
facially and all these kind of things
look like you as much as possible
because that's indicative of the fact
that you
probably have common ancestry
and of course in village societies that
would work really well and it probably
doesn't work so well for us because we
don't actually meet people that really
look like us very often these days but
in village society you know you can tell
tell it our village from that village
they just look different
and that's not just how they comb their
hair
physically did i see that you said that
men can actually smell when women are
ovulating yes yes
um so so this is the point that well
we can come back to ourselves just
finish the the
choice bit is that
the one thing you aren't looking for
somebody to be similar to you is in the
immune system because what you want
is your child to have as diverse as
an immune system as possible you did
then
narrowly it is so inbreeding is bad for
all sorts of reasons but one of them is
you end up with no variability in their
immune system to resist diseases when
you say immune system what do you mean
it the body's natural immune system this
is what produces all the white blood
cells and stuff that sort of attack and
cannibalize okay and genetic viruses
genetically people have a predisposition
to be what robust against certain types
of uh
viruses and and bacteria but maybe not
all of them so the goal is to kind of
spread the risk across yes okay okay yes
or it's it's
not necessarily particular resistance
particular but bacteria or what have you
but a very strong immune system which is
because the immune system is very
adaptive to what's thrown at it right it
learns
uh to recognize
uh foreign bodies that have invaded you
and this isn't just genetic this is
something which is going to be
influenced by if you were an adventurer
if you'd been away
no it's it's the it's the genetics of
the immune system itself this capacity
for the white essentially the white
blood cells to
identify the natural killer cells the nk
cells
uh to identify foreign bodies in your
system and seek and destroy as it were
and uh you know what you i mean there
will be an element probably from
different exposures
in terms of lineages
uh
that have you know sort of produced some
genetic adaptation to particular kinds
of viruses maybe but the essence of it
is you want
as much diversity as you can get there
and that
smelling somebody
is as the sort of semi-distance cue
is the best way to find that out and and
you know the famous cases are eskimos
and maori's rubbing noses and we all
think they're rubbing noses they're not
what they do is they put their noses
side by side and they sniff
and take in a deep breath
and it's called uh i forget the term uh
use uh how it's translated but
essentially it's breathing in the spirit
is that the equivalent of the european
air kiss on both eggs yes exactly the
same
thing this is why people pick babies up
and sniff them if you've ever watched
newborn babies when they're being sort
of passed around
everybody goes
holds them up to a big whiff of the baby
and pretends not to be sniffing but they
sniff there is a question about
so um and you know we get a lot of cues
from
uh
much more cues from smell than we really
like to think and we're actually quite
good i mean mothers can tell
uh their offspring from other people's
offspring by their smell alone
um
the and the the the the big issue uh um
really
in this context is perfume right perfume
billions of dollars are spent every year
on perfume billions of dollars and
everybody thinks
it's to cover up your natural bad odors
and it's not
you what you're doing is you buy perfume
that exaggerates your natural your
personal natural odors that's why there
are so many different perfumes it was
just covering it up we just have one
perfume and everybody
you know
like old spice aftershave just gets
loaded
no not not not with women
it's very carefully chosen
to
and that this is kind of how they build
up these perfumes is you know so they
kind of match
uh different
uh smell characteristics as it were
they're sniffers extremely good at
decomposing the smells in in different
perfect mixes
um at the
the people that do it for them
um but
what it's doing is actually exaggerating
your natural smell of course it helps to
cover up some of the bits you don't want
to
to to to smell of but but it's actually
you know really part and parcel of the
courtship strategy and that's why it's
been you know since time immemorial um
women in particular have done that
or used it
not to say that men also don't but it's
much much more important
in case women but your final so you've
had a good sniff
while you're sort of
grabbing the girl in a waltz or
something like that or pretending to
dance very close
in the club
um but the final
uh point really is comes with kissing
because that actually is direct
uh experience of of um in saliva saliva
is just full
of uh um you know sort of
immune system stuff as well as digestive
stuff so it's it gives you really
clear uh messages it was the best you
could do but that's your final because
that's invasive that's obviously the
final step in it so courtship is like
this series of steps
starting way out with distance cues
which are largely visual getting closer
and closer and closer into
literally into taste at the end
what do you think's going on with
non-reproductive sex then if you're
using contraception
well i mean it's it you know sex is
designed for for all animals never mind
humans to be a pleasurable experience
and therefore make you keep coming back
and doing it
what's interesting about humans is it's
clearly geared to reinforcing
the pair bond because
the
amount of sex that has to be
done
to conceive
is just outrageous you know no sensible
primate would ever you know
waste so much time in sex
gesture conceive and offspring also it's
very very quick three cycles and uh
primarily and and and the female be pres
pregnant it takes seems to take much
longer in humans and the only
explanation for that is simply to
prolong
the pleasurable components of sex to
reinforce the pair bond because what
happens
right
you have to remember it's all about
bonding and all our bonding comes
essentially through the endorphin system
in the brain which is
part of the
brain's management system for pain it's
an opiate on opioid technically so it's
rather similar effect to
morphine it makes you feel very relaxed
and woozy and
peace of the world and uh you know
trusting
of whoever you're doing the activity
with and and for primates that's done by
social grooming leafing through the
triggers
and the receptors and the skin
which trigger the endorphin system in
the brain specialized set of receptors
now we still do that that's why we go
around hugging people and patting them
on the shoulder and
stroking their
arms and things like that
but a lot of what we do
because we live in big groups bigger
groups than
any primate would ever
think of grooming with
uh in other words it's intimacy you know
you don't do it with everybody you only
do it it's
close ones but you won't now want to
bond a bigger group then a lot of the
things that we part of the social
toolkit
so
laughter singing dancing eating socially
together feasting telling emotional sob
stories
all these things trigger the endorphin
system and make you feel bonded to the
people you're doing it with
so you say are you saying that the
difficulty of
human females to get pregnant the fact
that it does take many attempts let's
say in order for that to happen
and maybe concealed ovulation as well or
the fact that it happens without us
being able to tell when a woman is like
equivalent of in the heat yes yes that
is
evolution
making it purposefully
more difficult or rarer
to occur
to encourage the man and the woman to
have more sex which is already
reinforced through the pleasure response
in order to increase the pair bond yes
yes
so cool
that is so because after all the sin is
uh the woman is pregnant
you know but it's done
well you know i mean the yeah okay
early stages of pregnancy
um uh uh you can obviously can still
have sex but later on
you know it starts to become so if every
woman got pregnant
the first mechanically tricky if every
woman got pregnant the first time that
she had sex with a man
it would be very unlikely for them to
form the sort of robust pair bond that
they would need in order to be able to
raise the child that is robin that is
absolutely fascinating and it's because
the reason this is working is it's a
a twofold mechanism in this particular
case
because
the stimulation
physical stimulation
of the skin
um all over the body
the hairy skin uh as opposed to the
palms of the hands and the soles of the
feet
um well we used to think there were no
receptors in there there's some doubt
about that now but all the sort of hairy
skin your arms the body the hair or head
and
legs
are full of these endorphin receptors or
the system that sets the endorphins off
in the brain
um and so the stimulation that's
given during
uh sex all the massaging and and so on
and so forth is triggering the endorphin
system like crazy
um and in addition to that you've got a
secondary system kicking in which is the
oxytocin system which is designed around
or
what it exists for well oxytocin started
laughing fishes
as a
mechanism for maintaining water balance
in the body so maybe complete sense it
makes complete sense to me
but in mammals it had the opposite it
was adapted to keep the water in rather
than out and therefore it became very
important
in terms of lactation
right so it plays an extremely important
role in uh the course of lactation to
ensure the the
uh woman has enough liquid to create
milk without
you know going up
killing herself
and therefore it's kind of been adapted
into
uh a hormone that causes mother infant
bonding and then seemingly from that
it's been adapted to cause
um
bonding to the romantic partner because
of all the stimulation both of the
breasts
and
of the vagina that trigger oxytocins as
well tysons are very short acting yes
they don't last very long but they're
very high it's like a very high hard hit
yes
whereas the endorphins are long and slow
line of cocaine not the tab of lsd
exactly i was i'll speak in language i
understand i wouldn't know officer but
um
i so is cuddling the same is that the
same response
holding right okay did i read in your
new book friends which we're going to
talk about another time that
the speed
that you rub
somebody with
needs to be slower than
one and a half inches per second that
you're moving across the skin in order
to get the optimal endorphin response
and this is some
uh vestigial
grooming picking
bugs out of the fur thing yep it's it's
three centimeters a second
uh if if you go substantially faster
than that it doesn't trigger the
receptors in the skin
and that's about the speed with which
the hands move across the fur parting
the fur during grooming in monkeys um so
they're looking for bits of rubbish and
stuff in the fur and you know and so
they're constantly parting the foe with
both hands and it's that
movement deforms the skin and triggers
these receptors
and it's been shown with babies newborn
babies that if you stroke them at
exactly three centimeters a second
it calms them down when they're crying
and makes them you know if they've got
to have as they do you know a pin prick
for
the test that they do
with newborn babies they're much less
bothered by they don't sort of go ouch
and make it make it better i want to get
back
right but if you do it at 30 centimeters
a second
it has absolutely no effect i don't know
how you rub
a baby which is probably only about 50
centimeters long at 30 centimeters a
second that's like i don't know i don't
know it's the rate
thank you for correcting me there right
so here's a question and this question
came from interstellar the film it's by
christopher nolan uh it's spectacular
and
it's this question that stuck with me
for a long time there's this lady who
has a felt sense that someone on a
different a distant planet is still
alive they're doing this journey to try
and
find a new world for humanity to live on
or something like that and in it she
brings up this question about why it is
that we love people we continue to love
people that have already died
and if love exists to encourage child
bearing and child rearing
why would we love people after they're
dead
oh i think that's because the difference
between platonic love
and romantic love
is
almost paper thin really
they're both based on on the same
framework or obviously warning
incorporates a sexual element which is
very specialized because
what happens with
in the context of falling in love is the
brain shuts down interest in other
people obviously this doesn't happen
every time but if you fall in love
properly
then
you lose interest in
alternative possibilities it's only
some time years later that you come out
of that rosy sunglasses
phase that you begin to become
interested in in other individuals it's
very very focused
friendships are very similar and
interestingly enough um
and this bears back to the earlier
discussion we had about females best
friends
uh this best friend forever phenomenon
bff phenomenon which is very
characteristic of women and very
uncharacteristic of men
um
seems to be
really important for women this goes
back to your
moral and emotional and physical support
mechanism that they need
when they're in
uh moving from one society to another
and you know everybody's related to the
husband and you're on your own
uh you know your support mechanism is
another
uh
woman girl who's in the same boat as you
say you know you can you can form an
alliance and then they're very important
then in helping each other with through
the business of
birth and child early child rearing
um those friendships
are very characteristic nearly always
uh women very occasionally about 15
percent of
women's best best friends forever are
actually a man
uh which must cause all sorts of
interesting dilemmas which we
need not go into
but the great majority 85 percent almost
all women have one and a great majority
of those are another woman and the
interviews that have been done with
women about these by the social
psychologists they just say
i need somebody who's on the same
emotional
wavelength as me many useless
for that kind of thing okay
uh i you know that's why you know i i
build these these relationships but i'm
sure it's much more to do with
the kind of forming these little
coalitions to buffer yourself against
the stresses of the rest of the group
and to provide child care support
and and that kind of remains constant
right the way through
uh life
and indeed your social networks
are very very gender biased 70 of men's
social networks their friends and family
are
men and 70 of women's are women and that
numb figure remains constant from the
age of
at five to the age of 85 doesn't
bat an eyelid
um
you just don't see that same kind of
emotional intensity in men's friendship
if you ask them have you got a best
friend
male friend they'll kind of go oh yeah
go drinking with jimmy a lot you know
but the truth is
if jimmy moves away and then goes and
lives in thailand for the rest of his
life because he's fed up with wherever
you live
as you do um
you know you kind of shrug your
shoulders and say well that's too bad um
i'll go and see if steve's available
men's friendships are much much more
club-like in that sense so for women
those their friendships are personalized
and dyadic and very focused on the
individual as an individual men's
friendship is kind of more casual
um
they may involve a lot of time
uh
doing stuff together but they're very
casual um and they're much more
club-like
why would that be why would that be
adaptive for each sex
well i think i think in the women's case
it's precisely because then typically
they're moving
between communities
or marriage
to um
an environment where everybody in the
group the community is related to the
husband
yes because the woman was the thing that
was passed around or given the woman was
the one that was expected to move she
needed a steady rock that would go with
yeah yeah yeah well she doesn't
necessarily to go with her she just has
to be able to find somebody in that new
environment of course all the young
girls will also be in the same boat so
they'll share lots of things you can't
and what's characteristic of friendships
is you form friendships with people who
are very similar to you
in all sorts of different aspects
including
you know how how they view the world
they live in and the support kind of
elements that they need
um whereas i think the the male issue is
simply goes back to the fact that every
single hunter-gatherer and well
horticultural society in fact i suppose
still in
industrialized western societies
the male's
most important function the young male's
most important function is defense
so they all have these warrior grades
certainly
once you're into the agricultural phase
you have these warrior grades where
young men are
bonded as groups and they they form very
intense
friendships but it's a friendship with a
group
all the guys who are
circumcised together
however they you know whatever the
um
uh
process of of going from childhood to
manhood is always involves pain some
form
and
frightening experiences
take them out into the jungle in the
night
and and all the older men will creep
around in the bushes and make howling
noises and scare the wits out of these
poor kids but the result of that is that
utterly bonded it's exactly what you see
in the military even today
right
guys are being shot at it's terrifying
forever afterwards you're deeply bonded
to those guys is the reason for the male
friendship being able to be swapped in
and out to account for the fact that
you're going to have casualties then i
guess so yeah yeah interesting that you
you you don't get
so attached to an individual that
uh
you might want to supposed to go until
the job yeah yeah yeah yeah so one one
thing that i just thought about
you mentioned
male and female bonding during
relationships oxytocin
and endorphins
i
learned last year about vasopressin and
the role that it has for men
particularly
i'm less convinced oh tell me tell me
more
well it was
the investor president plays a very
similar role
uh to oxytocin in the sense that it was
involved in water balance in some way
originally
it's certainly being banded about as the
male equivalent of oxidation certainly
in the early literature when they were
talking up oxytocin as the
uh love hormone and the cure to you know
the secrets of the universe
um
of course oxytocin is primarily
uh present in in females we're talking
about female mammals in general
um you know so it was the argument was
uh
you know it it's what
creates
mother offspring bonding in mammals so
that they will invest they you know if
they don't
nurture and cuddle this wretched little
squirming thing you know it's not going
to survive you know it's not built to
survive themselves you have to have
something that makes the female just
kind of focus on on
being completely altruistic and and and
nurturing this this little thing until
it's old enough to stand on its entry
feet
and then they were left with the thing
well you know
what happens in um
uh the case of males uh you know you
need something else if you're going to
have males
in monogamous social systems this is all
done on voles the difference between
polygamists and monogamous voles
so what and partly the story was that um
oxytocin played a stronger role in
monogamous in males of
monogamous species involves than was the
case in polygamous promiscuous ones
but then somebody lit on to
vasopressin and there was some nice
swedish work on twins showing that
males with high levels of
vasopressin were
more reliable
essentially in
their romantic relationships so males
with the wrong allele
for vasopressin tended to be here today
and gone tomorrow and
you know they would sort of
not very they would act first and think
afterwards let's say
um but
it's not clear that that it's really
playing a very strong world and we've
done a huge genetic study
um
and it was all done in britain
so it might be different to other people
um but it showed no signature at all for
face oppressing in any kind we looked at
three different levels of sociality so
your your social predisposition your
romantic dyadic romantic relationships
and your embeddedness in in the wider
social network
and you know dopamine plays a very
strong role occutation plays a very
specific role in the context of romantic
relationships and endorphins
again play a very important role across
the across the board
but vasopressin there was absolutely no
signature at all no difference so
i'm a little skeptical of
the literature
people tend to latch on to something
get very excited about it and then of
course the media gets excited and it all
gets blown out of abortion
and the the object lesson here is the
vol studies because it was all based
around difference between monogamous
falls and
polygamous voles in terms of oxytocin
essentially
oxidation genes
except that when somebody did a study of
and that was comparison of two whole
species when somebody did a comparison
of the oxytocin
genetics across all false species there
was no correlation at all with
monogamy versus promiscuity and then
somebody else point discovered that
actually you can explain
the
polygamy uh promiscuity versus monogamy
difference between the original two
vowel species american vowel species on
the basis of their endorphin genes
anyways oh sorry all the vassal pressing
got wrapped up within the existing
framework and it wasn't needed look
robin you are absolutely spectacular
thank you very much for coming on today
uh we didn't even get onto betrayal we
didn't even get onto the book that i
meant to bring you on to talk about so
i'm just gonna have to drag you back so
you can have another glass of wine and
spend an evening with me uh if people
want to keep up to date with the stuff
that you're doing either out of your
work or online is there any way that
they should go
um really the best place is
the books actually um the books are
written for
uh the layman they're me thinking out
loud really trying to pull the big story
together out of all the research we and
others have done
and
i hope they're a pleasure to read as
well as being informative they're meant
to be informative
um so i'd go there
it's much the best place but it's been
great fun talking to you so robin i
appreciate you very much thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]